[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK DUBOIS: Hi.
My name is Mark Dubois.
I'm the founder of Upande Ltd.,
a local-based company
here in Nairobi, Kenya.
We do lots of application
development for various
clients, including some of our
own products, and using a lot
of Google Map API for that.
And I'd like to show
you some of those.
So welcome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BERNADETTE NDEGE: Hi.
My name is Bernadette Ndege.
I work for Upande Ltd.
as a JS consultant.
I mainly work with different
data formats.
And for this particular project
that is Virtual Kenya,
I was working with conversion
from the normal ordinary
shapefiles into a format
that people can
interact with easily.
And that is Google Earth.
So they're converted to KMLs.
This is an example of one file,
average annual rainfall
for February.
And before they use a download,
they have the
privilege of previewing what
they are about to download in
this Google app plug-in.
So after download, then they can
further interact with it
on Google app and their
own machine.
And as you can see, it's
interactive and
very easy to use.
You don't need any technical
knowledge.
One of the other things we did
is we combined some of these
lays and we put it into a story,
very exciting, very
easy to use, and into
a Google app tool.
So this is an example.
[VOICEOVER ON APPLICATION]
The location of various
resources on the earth, their
relationships with each other,
the analysis of location of
places, and their spatial
distribution.
BERNADETTE NDEGE: What I like
about working with Google Maps
API is its flexibility.
It allows you to build upon an
already-provided free base
map, but at the same time,
giving you the flexibility of
customizing your own
applications and using it in
very many different ways.